so alright this this is a I wouldn't say
first it's basically at first this guess
is a first on here in la cascada but
it's a first to get someone this much of
a there's another way say in the studio
we were all very praising of him this
morning
this man is is thought it was a national
hero by a lot of folks and we just so
happened that I guess his daughter's a
fan as a mug club member and so we were
able to get him Daren our Booker got him
on the line this is the man who pursued
and I believe I believe I'll let him
explain it shot the shooter the Texas
shooter who everyone's been talking
about right now that I hate sitting here
of the hour because I know he's gonna be
humble and downplay it but Stephen
Willeford thank you for being here sir
thank you for having me on well I know
how emotional of a time this must be and
probably exhausting everyone's been
wanting a piece of you in the press so I
really do appreciate you making the time
and listen if ever you just don't want
to discuss it
I know legally maybe can't answer
question just feel free to say pass and
you know my moronic self will move on
down the trail okay so explain for
people who don't know you know what
happened we've all read we've all heard
about the Texas shooting storylines two
very confusing this storyline is very
confusing for a lot of people as far as
I understand you were across the street
you're in the neighborhood and you got
your firearm and pursue this individual
just explain it for them to the audience
for people who they've been making kind
of putting this together with bits and
pieces from the media I live in a little
small community of Sutherland and wig
number in the hundreds definitely not in
the thousands they're all community I
want to dairy there that I was support
generationally I love my community I
love the people that are there I know
most of the people that went to the
church there and most of them knew my
great-grandparents the older ones that's
how far back it goes
and why I knew anyway our yeah go ahead
sorry I know how much you care for them
I know how emotional must be and if I
can help you anyway let me know here the
community knows you well if ever one
who's been interviewed spoken so highly
of you I don't think there's anyone as a
bad word to say it all about about this
Manchester then people pivot right away
to politicizing the issue of gun control
so let's put that on the Shelf here what
happened that you know the day of the
shooting when this this story broke what
happened what did you hear what went
through your mind what went down that
day I I was I was at home yeah I was
actually in my my room relaxing and I
started hearing a sound and it sounded
like someone tapping on my window I'm
about about a block away from the church
okay yeah my older daughter ran in she
was she was cleaning dishes in the
kitchen and she ran into my room and
said dad doesn't that sound like gunfire
and I told her I said that sounds like
someone tapping on the window and and it
was just a rapid tapping and I went to
the window and open the window and I
could not see anything but I followed
her into the kitchen when I got into my
kitchen it's not more volume and I could
tell that it sounded like gunfire I said
oh my god it sounds like gunfire
I ran to my safe and opened my safe and
I am my daughter ran outside got in her
car and drove around the block well I
got my ar-15 out of the safe and I ran
back and I grabbed a box of ammunition
and she came in and said dad there's
someone in tactical black I think Oh
gears the Baptist Church and I said call
your mom
my wife and
my daughter that's here too now and her
husband were working on their house
we're building their house and they were
over at my property that's five miles
down the road and and she called them
and I said stay put stay put we have an
active shooter situation at the Baptist
Church - stay where you are because I
knew they were far enough out of town
they were no danger right oh I opened
the box of ammunition and I grabbed a
handful because I was hearing shots one
after another rapid pace and and I just
grabbed a handful and I started loading
a magazine and I started out the door
and my other daughter I told her love me
another magazine and I knew she couldn't
come give me a magazine it was busy work
I was trying to give her something to do
keep her in her house for thought I was
thinking you need it so you actually
just you hadn't you had the time and
spatial awareness to think
give her something so that she's
distracted I guess I've been a foreman
before and construction and sometimes
you just gotta get busy work to someone
I have to get him out to get him out of
your hair yes okay but but in and my
daughter is she is great girl and she's
actually I I started training all my
kids when they were eight years old they
were NRA distinguished experts Wow so
they are the firearms yeah I was a
instructor but I did not want anybody
else that might be a target right Wow
good there and and I I ran out of the
house and some of them people said why
did you run out barefoot as I didn't
have shoes on
the simple answer well my answer was was
every time I heard a shot I was thinking
that was assigned to someone else right
that shot was assigned he was shooting
and another person every time I heard a
shot fire and I didn't have time to put
shoes on I'm it's the time of the year
that I'm growing my Santa beard because
I fell on a motor because I go on a
motorcycle ride with the Baptist Church
where we deliver toys for boys and girls
of low-income around Wilson County and I
ride with a Baptist Church it was under
attack well so you so high shoes on and
then what do you do you get into your
vehicle do you run straight to the
Cherno I'm a block away or less of less
than a block away they're their catty
corner behind me in my house her house
behind me and they're across the street
on the other side okay and so I ran over
there and I ran across the neighbor's
house that was right across from there
and as I approached the neighbor's house
I see a gray SUV setting in the middle
of the highway in park with the engine
running and the driver's side door open
and it was out of place and I was
focused on that trying to figure out
that and kind of looking back behind the
vehicle and and I don't know that I had
tunnel vision or what the deal was but I
saw the shooter come from around the
front of the vehicle okay
and at this time he had a handgun in his
in his hand and I didn't know but my
daughter said that it had an ar-15 but
when I saw him he had a handgun okay and
he had a tactical helmet on like like a
SWAT team would use with with a black
visor and he had Kevlar vest and you
could tell it was a bullet test he had
that and you know I'm a Christian sure
and I believe I believe at that point
and maybe this sounds a little off just
some of your visit there
viewers that aren't Christians I believe
the Holy Spirit was on me because I had
the presence of mind to look at what was
going on and as we exchanged fire I
noticed that the side was one of those
tactical vests that velcro's across
meaning he has Kevlar in the front
Kevlar in the back nothing in the side
how far away was he at this point for
for context would you say 20 yards okay
so 20 yards so you can see that clearly
and someone like you is trained with
firearms to it you know 20 yards as well
within what you would practice with I
had a ar-15 with an EOTech moment sure
and I trained at 20 yards that's no snow
real great amazing shot I shot between
the two Kevlar plates well that is what
not to just heat trace oh no everyone
else will but to have that frame of mind
like you said that force sight I know
people are going to be asking mahir NRA
instructor training military background
because most people would not think to
look for this to be aware of your
surroundings it is it is remarkable well
that's what I'm telling you I can't I
can't explain the clarity of mind that I
had I can't explain it and and and not
only back but I was using the neighbor's
Dodge pickup truck he had a four-wheel
drive Dodge pickup truck in his driveway
and I was using it all I had all he had
for a shot for me as my head because I
was behind the truck and using it for
cover okay and we exchanged fire and he
hit the neighbors car's windshield he
hit the neighbor's house and he got into
the vehicle and I fired again and he
fired two more shots through his side
actually he shot fired two shots through
a side window first and it put notice
the two distinct pistol shots coming
through the sides of the window and I
fired my our 15 again and it took the
window down it fell okay and I took I
took another saw and at this point I'm
stupid where his head will be right and
he started the vehicle and he turned and
he turned down five thirty nine which is
which is a highway and he took off took
one more shock and what I perceived
would be about his head through the back
windshield and it shattered okay
and he blasted down the road I looked to
my left and there was a another a pickup
truck at the stop sign that apparently
witnessed the bubble thing and I ran up
and I tapped on his window and I said
that guy just shot up the Baptist Church
and we got a stop and he unlocked his
door and we gave pursuit and thank God
that he did because you know obviously
you have to think from his point of view
he comes up with a gun and says you know
this is a tactic that kidnappers or
people who are car jackers use a lot hey
I need your help and he I don't thank
God you both got it right he he did he
did he did witness this the exchanged
gunfire right he saw the guy student at
me also and he saw him run out from from
the Baptist Church and he saw him in the
black tactical gear and me and me when
no shoes on yeah he might have that
point he might've said okay that's the
bad guy the guy with the black visor not
the guy with the Santa beard and there's
no flip-flop so he lets you in a few
windows now been shot through and how
far is he from you as you behave and
closer yeah he had a considerable lead
with the body but he he left out of
there we shot across in a major
intersection at full speed and again I
had the presence of mind I I dropped the
magazine but because I had to remember I
didn't load a magazine I just grabbed a
handful and stuck a man didn't count
right
I dropped the magazine down and I looked
and I have one round in the magazine
meaning I had one round in the
one in the magazine and I pushed it back
up in place he had called 911 at this
point and he was talking to 911 and
obviously the Wilson County Police
Department and everybody else has got an
active shooter at the Sutherland Springs
Church right and so we started talking
to dispatch and telling them that we
were in pursuit of him going for John
5:39 and they said which direction he
was headed toward Seguin North 539 and I
said can you seem and about that time he
came into view of the n we started
catching him okay so he comes into view
and started catching him what does that
mean you start closing the gap do you
bump them no no we were still three cars
behind him but we could see him and you
can see the back windshield was knocked
out and we were making up ground and
they asked us specifically where is he
and there was a crossroad there that 7r2
27 or something like that the crosses
and goes back to Lavernia and he had
just passed that and we told dispatch he
just passed the road that cuts off and
goes to laverna
and so we're giving them we're letting
them know where he is right and and we
started closing on him real fast at that
point any veered off the road and he
almost stopped and I reached down and I
started to open the door and I had my
rifle in my hand and I was gonna stand
behind the door and then he took off
again and he hit a highway sign and
folded over the back of it over the top
of this vehicle he got back up on the
pavement and ran up about a hundred more
yards and then down into the far ditch
on the other side and stopped okay and
at that point I told the driver and I
didn't know his name at all his name
ended up his name's Johnny
though the driver I said just get down
you have nothing and just get down get
out of the fire
let's just get below the dash and I open
the door and I got out and I use the
truck again to lay my rifle across the
hood of the truck and I started yelling
which is not like me well I think it's
forgivable in this instance I don't
think anyone's gonna be too upset about
it
so you're yelling your rifle is on there
it's he at this point saying anything
back or if this is where he's already
he's quiet there's there's nothing left
coming loose from him there's no
movement there's no I I don't know I
don't know at this point I didn't know
what was going on in the vehicle what
was going on if if anything I didn't
know and so I sat there and Johnny said
estimated between five and seven minutes
it's y'all got to tell you it seemed
like an eternity right I've got I've got
my rifle trained on the side window of
the driver's side and just waiting for
any sign of anything and I'm yelling the
whole time and I I remember one time
yelled out where's the police and just a
short time after I yelled that I was
focused on the SUV I heard a PA system
come on and said driver get out of the
vehicle with your hands up I'm gonna
hurt it begin I laid my rifle over the
hood of the truck and I walked back to
the back of the truck with my hands up
like this and the officer looked at me
so not you
I didn't want him to think that there
was any threat with me at all right but
now that was kind of a funny moment
because I realized at that time that
there's only one spot bar and I go right
and so I went ahead and and I held my
rifle trained onto the car until I saw
about six different police officers pull
up and I thought my job was done and I
put the rifle on the back of the toolbox
to the pickup truck and started to walk
back and they said no no no stay where
you are stay where you are and they
drove a car up so that I could get
behind the car and be shielded as is he
backed up and got me away from the scene
the Wilson County Police Department
should be proud of themselves I'm sure
they aren't I'm sure they're proud of
you I wouldn't be surprised if some kind
of a metal or achievement here because
you know listen this is you did so much
and this is when people often say well
call the police you see in this instance
they did as good of a job as they
possibly could and in that instance
right if you weren't there this is one
thing that I would like your perspective
on the media says well this didn't
necessarily stop at the shooting had
already occurred but who knows just
during those five to seven minutes what
what kind of damage he could have done
if not for someone like you as you said
that's an eternity I'm going to tell you
and and I found out later they said he
had multiple firearms in the vehicle and
lots of ammunition and I don't know what
his plan was but my my my my thought and
looking at it is he had active ball
helmet and a Kevlar vest he wasn't
through yeah and there and there was the
River Oaks Baptist Church two in the
same direction that he left right yeah
by no means saying that that's where he
was going
but they were in the middle of my Sunday
morning services - yeah
well it doesn't seem like a getaway a
guy who keeps his car running and has
several more weapons and ammunition
that's not someone who's just looking to
get out of Dodge
so I mean what are you I mean I I don't
want to Barbara Walters this but do you
have it what are your feelings like now
they they mixed I mean I know people
talk about what it's like in these
scenarios and you can never imagine
taking a life but in this instance
knowing so many people in your town and
saving so many people what are you what
are you feeling like now I I'm having
all kinds a issues and I now I know I
probably need to talk to I know police
officers go through some sort of
counseling and I probably need to talk
to a counselor and I'm going to because
I can't I can't put my finger on what my
feelings are
I'm a little bit angry at the media oh
that's gonna really make you happy but I
felt well my my issue is is I feel like
a prisoner in my own home because I
can't step out my door I I know and
that's I appreciate you doing this
interview it's feel free to be off at
any time I can imagine you want some
time to yourself but not all differently
either this is crazy crazy they're
coming up to my door and they're
sticking cards in my door Sheriff Joe
Tackett told them if they come up into
my yard again he was gonna arrest them
and when they left they were right back
gosh and I would love to you know and
and this is where I want the focus for
this to go sure right here not me
I want the focus to go to the families
of the community that I grew up in and
the people that I love they're the
people that I know
the church was very small congregation
and 27 people are dead children are dead
20 amol 20 or so were injured
[Music]
that's decimated their congregation
there's very few left in their
congregation right the pastor of the
church
Frank Pomeroy was him and his wife were
in Oklahoma they're 40 girl daughter was
killed I can only imagine I mean that's
just that's a that's a long drive home
where's there a place people can go to
support the church and its its members I
was you know a lot of people feel
helpless as to how they can help in an
instance like this oh you know please
figure it out again I've been a prisoner
in my own home I have no idea
I can't they're having a memorial at the
baseball stadium and the media is gonna
be there and guess who can't be there if
media's there yeah I can imagine it's
got to be tough I want to hug somebody's
people yeah I don't even know which
one's my friends made it and didn't I
don't know cuz the media has not given
me any information and they're keeping
me from seeing any of these people have
have the media been helpful with you at
all have some have been contentious how
have they been treating you I know
obviously they're they're being very
persistent after well and I'm gonna tell
you I did a interview with a young man
that was on my youth shooting club when
I used to do an NR a shooting club he
went on to be went on to harden
Christian University where he graduated
and he is now an anchorman in a arc dog
NewsCenter okay and he called me up and
he said I would love to help you if I
can help you in any way he said I don't
want to sound like I'm just looking
first story he said but you know me he
said he's a dude in business and you can
have a friend doing it he said he said
tell me and he says my my my possible
hotel will send me right away and we can
be down tomorrow guys have come down
yeah and I I have done a interview with
him also I did that before I did this
and and he said that which that John
five o'clock is it would move on to
media lets farther out yeah after they
had had it so in that sense the media
has been very helpful and I hope now
that I did an interview that maybe they
will for the most part leave the way I
at least out from in front my home and
go focus on what should be focused on
helping the community and however they
can write you people that grew up in the
city or grew up in small towns you gotta
understand so I'm gonna land Springs is
a small small town where we walk outside
and we see our neighbors the neighbors a
new our parents and our grandparents the
neighbors have new us when we grew up
and we say hi and we stand up we can
still see the stars at night
that's Sutherland Sprint's that's where
you would always want to be yeah well
that's when I tell you what I know if we
live there people would want to be your
neighbor I wouldn't want to be near
wherever someone like like like you is
and and let me tell you this we
appreciate you so much coming out here
and doing this today with your family if
we can help in any way let me
say this one one thing here just as you
saw with Ken bone and I'm sure you've
seen the media's politicize the gun
issue already I don't want to do that
but there are going to be some people
out there unfortunately who are not
going to focus in the town who are not
going to be looking to be helpful and
are going to be doing some digging doing
anything they can to try and discredit
you we have some brilliant researchers
here we have some brilliant people at
lotto with Crowder who can help with a
lot of this if ever and also a platform
if there is a way that people can help
you or help the city let us know and
we'll make sure that we're an outlet
that's available to you because my god
man I mean this is according to media
people like you people as pure hearted
and as capable don't exist and it is an
unbelievable story we I mean you're in
it now see but you've you're a huge
moment in history what you did ok can I
think
can I say something being and I I don't
feel comfortable saying it just anywhere
but maybe with you guys if I had run out
of in the house and maybe this is a
political plug or whatever but if I had
run out of the house with a pistol and
faced bulletproof vests and Kevlar
helmets it might have been futile right
I know I and I ran out with an ar-15 and
that's what he was shooting the place up
with right and it's and and I hate to
politicize that but that's reality yeah
no listen to thank God that you did and
I I don't want to draw any kind of
politicization out of you to me
unfortunately the media is already doing
it right before we came on here was
slate saying well this actually isn't
true this narrative because the shooting
was over and you know what listen I will
do this since you don't want to because
you're you're so kind and want to focus
on on rebuilding and helping when people
say why do you need an ar-15 people say
why do you need X amount of rounds this
is why Steve Williford is wise because
you cannot take into account what a good
person with the firearm what a good
person who obeys the law who
to help his neighbors who knows his
neighbors names who wants to go out and
save their lives or even needs to save
as you cannot take all those factors
into account and so that's why you don't
have the ability or right
to remove a man like this his right to
protect himself and thank God that you
did man I mean I don't know anyone now
who would say I sure wish Stephen
Willeford didn't have an ar-15 I think a
lot of people hid in their knees tonight
thanking the Lord for you why not what I
can tell you is if the shooting was over
if he wasn't intending more damage it
was indeed over there was going to be a
shootout with police at some point right
yeah and I stopped that also and and I'm
not saying that to say that but I'm
saying that one way or the other
someone's life was gonna be in danger
and yeah I was mine or whoever yeah but
the police police would have showed me
and they probably were better trained
and whatever but I was there when it
happened
yeah no I was there when nobody else was
there when he shot a hole through my
neighbor's house and and came within a
few feet of his his two-year-old son
it's it's it's only it's one of those
you know I can't even try and pretend to
empathize or no and listen I know that
like you said you'll be probably seeing
a counselor and there are a lot of
conflicting emotions but I can tell you
that there are hundreds of millions of
people not only in this country but
across the globe right now who will
absolutely see you as an inspiration and
so I know this is a horrible tragedy but
if there is any kind of a silver lining
it's that people have seen someone like
you and you've inspired a lot of people
out right now not only from this
interview but you've inspired them just
with with the ability to do good and
take action when other people might be
afraid too a lot of people wouldn't you
know listen there are a lot of people in
your scenario who would close their
doors and hide and not only thinking of
your daughter's thinking of your family
having the ability that the situational
awareness but being considered of the
police and like you said saving
anyway you look at this it doesn't
matter how is going to play out there
are more people alive today and there
are more lives improved today because
you were there because you had your
firearm and because you acted and I hope
that that makes it a little bit of an
easier pill to swallow
because it means a lot to everyone else
watching I I've I've been saying that
this is tough this is tough and nobody
wants this and there's nobody wants this
but I would do it again if I had to yeah
even how tough it is and how people are
doing whatever they're gonna say and say
and whatever I would do it again if I
had to yeah
Annette listen that's that says a lot
about we talk about that a lot it says a
lot about your character people being in
uncomfortable situations and doing what
they have to anyway and looking back
right now and what imagine is probably
the it's not certainly one of the most
uncomfortable moments of your life and
saying listen I would do it again not
doing it for you the guy wasn't coming
into your house you did it entirely for
other people and and I hope the media
catches that I hope the media in all
their politicization of this but they
pick up on that give you some space in
truly recognize you know we talk about
all the the horror in the tragedy media
a selfless act that saved lives doesn't
get as much of a headline coverage but
yes are you were going to say something
I was gonna say something too that's
what makes you brave you know I my dad
tell me that when I was young you know
what the definition if he had that
conversation with me he said you know
what brave is I said it means not being
afraid he said no it means doing the
right thing in the face of being afraid
no one expects you to be fearless no one
expects you to go out there and be John
Rambo I would imagine that if it were me
I'd be yelling to my wife to get my
brown pants I would have long since all
of us
hey at least I brought some laughter
that hopefully uh made your day a little
brighter but I know here's the thing I
think a lot of people who don't know
anything about firearms and don't know
anything about small towns and don't
know anything about police response
times they think that it's a yahoo out
there looking for a bar fight and
someone like you who is willing to admit
that you were terrified as anyone would
be and was clearly acting selflessly
this is not how the media has portrayed
even by the way even pro-gun media good
guys with guns right it's often tacked
to cool and it's often seen as people
who are ultra trained I want there to be
millions as many millions as part of
people like you out there I don't want
the guy who just has an arsenal and the
tattoos and trained I want there to be
millions of people who are able to
defend themselves and their neighbors
with firearms so that we can have more
good people out there like like Steven
Willeford and I'm not just saying that
I've talked about that on the show a lot
I've said listen there are people out
there you don't necessarily know their
circumstances and here we go here's your
story no one could have imagined this no
one could have put this in a box and it
unfolded and there you were it's it's
it's amazing and we really really
appreciate it and hopefully your
daughter's now or are you at least cool
dad for a day they given you that know
what I said with your oh sorry yeah the
internet connection I know is so with
your daughters are you at least cool dad
for a day are they giving you a break
are you are you gonna cool died in the
house here for a little bit I you know I
we my daughters ride motorcycles um
getting my son my son I I have my son
too and I ride motorcycles with my son
and my wife we all ride Harley's like
crazy that is but but we all ride
together and I guess I've always been in
their eyes a little bit
kind of the cool cool dad I guess I
haven't I'm a blessed man I am a very
very blessed man because all my kids
still love me and they think I'm alright
yeah and we still do we ride together
and I I now have a daughter that's
married and son so son-in-law there I
got my son that's married he's sitting
right here with his beautiful wife and
my oldest daughter is about to get
married
Wow yeah well if they can hear me hear
daughters and sons either get it get
your dad a gift make sure it's better
than some crappy number one dad mug get
him something to look at your hole I
know your daughter's a muffler we will
get you anything you want listen
anything you want any resources we can
provide for you because I not to be a
downer at all but as you know the media
can be ruthless and we are going to
provide any all of our tools at your
disposal if there's anything we can do
let us know and to end on a positive
note with this you know we often hear
this in church we often hear it with one
of your tragedies or people who lash out
they say you know hurt people hurt
people hurt people hurt people we hear
that a lot well you know what he just
heard from mr. Wilford he said I am a
very blessed man and you know what
blessed people bless other people and in
this instance this guy has blessed we
don't know how many that's this is a
great example you know how many lives
were saved but we know it's something
and we know that it matters and I know
in the face of tragedy it's it doesn't
mean a whole lot to some people in the
in the temporary but in the permanent it
means it means a whole lot we really
appreciate your brother mr. Wilford
thank you for taking the time and go go
go do something with your kids until
tell the people putting cards through
your slot to take a hike we gave you
permission to please please if you can
if you can find a place and I'm sure the
Baptist Church would you know stop in
Sutherland Springs would accept
donations I'm sure there's a lot of
a lot of funeral expenses coming up and
a lot of things I am again that isn't
even the church that I go to right now
you plug but but it is a church that's
near and dear close to my heart and they
need help
will any prayers they need prayers and
they need that everyone can be riding
there that their prayers and you know
you can send them letters but we'll be
looking for either if there's a GoFundMe
or if they can go to the website we will
make sure to post about it as do we know
Jared if there's anything yet I don't
think we know yet but as soon as there's
a definitive way to tangibly support
them we'll get it up on the website and
we'll get it in the link to this
interview we'll go back and re-edit it
retroactively Lee to fix it please
everyone out there listen if you're an
atheist if you're a Buddhist if you're
at a list if you're and I don't know us
I don't care but these are fellow
Americans who need help look at it that
way and Steven thank you so much man we
really appreciate it thank you
hey did you like this video it what you
didn't oh you're a cat person well that
makes sense disregard him and or her /z
everyone else hit the subscribe button
and leave your comment below as to why
you like this video I you know what
crazy cat you can get back you can you
can comment below too as to why you
don't like it